the Halloween franchise has made so many
twists and turns that trying to sort us
out the story can be a little confusing
no worries though we've laid out the
whole timeline in detail from that first
night of Tara to Michael's bloody return
he is the entire Halloween story finally
explained Halloween opens on Halloween
night in 1963
Judith Myers should be babysitting a six
year old brother Michael but what she's
actually doing is making out with a
boyfriend so Michael decides he's going
to spend his evening doing some killing
after slaughtering his sister
he's institutionalized and his
psychiatrist dr. Sam Loomis becomes
convinced that Michael is pure evil and
should never be allowed back into the
world but in 1978
Michael escapes and heads back to his
hometown looking to pick up right where
he left off money gets home he finds
high schooler Laurie Strode hanging
around so of course he decides to make
her and her friends as next targets for
the rest of the night Michael stalks and
kills Laurie's friends one by one but
Laurie is stronger than he gives her
credit for and she manages to fend him
off long enough to allow Loomis to
arrive on the scene and shoot him six
times knocking him off a balcony and
onto the ground below that same night
Laurie is taken to Haddonfield Memorial
Hospital
Michael survives his fall from the
balcony and follows Laurie because he's
not one to let his victims get away it's
also discovered that Laurie as surprised
Michael's younger sister and Michael is
even bigger surprise possibly being kept
alive because of a Samhain curse Michael
wanders through the hospital in search
of Laurie killing anyone and everyone
that gets in his way
while Loomis suss is inevitable descent
into madness trying to convince anyone
within earshot of Michael's evil
immortality in a final confrontation
Michael stabs Loomis in the stomach but
not before Loomis sets the hospital up
to explode Laurie gets out in time but
Michael and Loomis are trapped inside
when the building goes up in flames
Michael Myers takes a back seat in
Halloween 3 which takes place a few days
prior to the holiday when a man is
killed in a Northern California hospital
by a group of mysterious well-dressed
men dan chalice the doctor in charge of
his care takes it upon himself to try
and solve the case he traces the crime
all the way back to silver shamrock
novelties and a man
Connell Cochran who somehow managed to
steal a piece of Stonehenge he plans to
use it as part of a sacrifice involving
children and a trio of Halloween masks
with the goal of reclaiming the Samhain
holiday for witches but Dan thwart
Cochran's plan for the most part there
are robots killer bugs and the
possibility of a whole lot of child
death but no Michael Myers a decade
after the hospital explosion Michael
awakens from a coma just in time to
Hunter's niece Jamie on Halloween Jamie
as it happens as a seven year old
daughter of Lauri who died in a car
accident
Jamie is currently living with another
family but her true lineage isn't a
secret so she's bullied pretty heavily
Halloween 4 is a pretty straightforward
slasher flick in that the bulk of it
consists of Michael Myers killing a
bunch of poorly developed characters in
the most ridiculous ways imaginable but
eventually Loomis returns because he
somehow also managed to survive the
hospital explosion and he helps Jamie
defeat her uncle with the help of a town
lynch mob sadly it seems as though
psychopathy runs in the family
because after Michael falls through a
mineshaft Jamie tries to kill her foster
mother with a pair of scissors
Michael wounded from the attempt on his
life in Halloween four crawls into a
cave and immediately passes out he wakes
up on Halloween Eve a year later in the
care of another cave dweller Michael
kills him and sets course for his niece
who's been living as a mute of the
Haddonfield children's clinic for the
last year it's clear Jamie and Michael
are connected on a deeper level than
just blood that Sewer psychically paired
so everything Michael does from here on
out Jamie sees after his killing spree
Jamie tries to appeal to his emotions
but Michael isn't interested in anything
other than killing Loomis swoops in but
winds up suffering a stroke
there's no hero here just a random set
of circumstances that leads to Michael's
arrest in the end a strange man in black
who's been following Michael this entire
time come to the police station to
retrieve him six years later we learn
that the man in black is the leader of a
druid cult that's connected to Michael
on account of a marquee has on the
inside of his rest
turns out it's related to the so called
curse of thorn the thing responsible for
both Michaels immortality and his and
satiable desire to kill his family
Michaels work isn't done in Haddonfield
and soon very soon he'll come home
Jamie Nell 14 has delivered a baby in
the captivity of the Colts immediately
after giving birth she tries to escape
the Colts clutches and outrun her uncle
she fails and Michael kills her in a
barn the rest of the film shifts focus
to Tommy Doyle that now a dull boy that
Laurie Strode used to babysit he's
obsessed with the curse of thorne and
with the old Myers home in general
eventually thanks as help Loomis is able
to take Michael down or is he Laurie
Strode makes her return to the French
art of Halloween h2o 20 years later a
film that gets back to basics
effectively wiping out everything that's
happened after Halloween to Michael
Myers is still family but Laurie is
alive having faked her death and she's
working as a headmistress of a son
John's private boarding school in
California Michael reappears 20 years
after the hospital explosion and manages
to track Laurie down by way of an old
file one of Loomis's colleagues had on
hand in spite of her overprotective
nature Laurie can't protect John and his
friends from Michael's wrath and on
Halloween night the masked killer stalks
and kills pretty much everyone at the
school before Laurie can subdue him
[Music]
Laurie doesn't stop there though she
hijacks a coroner's van with Michaels
body sentence a slasher through the
windshield pinned him to a fence and
then takes an axe to his head all these
years later Laurie has finally gotten
her revenge except for one tiny detail
the man Laurie decapitated wasn't
actually Michael it was a paramedic with
a crushed larynx and Michael had tricked
her into thinking was him
three years later Laurie has convinced
the staff at grace Anderson sanitarium
that she's basically comatose while she
waits for a final final showdown with
her brother things don't go as planned
and Laurie winds up with a knife in her
back before she plummets of the hospital
roof
[Music]
the focus then turns to the old Myers
house where a group of college kids have
agreed to start an investigative
webseries Michael follows a group into
the house and proceeds to kill each
hopeful internet star all in front of a
live audience who assumes for a good
part of the night that everything
happening is fake when the Maya's house
is accidentally set ablaze
Michael is trapped inside and supposedly
dies you may have thought Laurie Strode
was out for good but 20:18 Halloween
made the decision to retcon everything
after the 1978 original which means at
this time there's no sibling drama no
that's just a bit that some people made
up to make him feel better I think and
most importantly Laurie is very much
alive although she spent four decades
living like a slasher movie equivalent
of a doomsday prepper Michael has been
locked up at Smith's Grove sanitarium
but after a pair of investigative
reporters come to interview him he
decides 40 years is long enough behind
bars and sets out for a final faceoff
with a babysitter that got away
Laurie on the other hand has a strained
relationship with her daughter Karen but
her granddaughter Allison wants to mend
fences everything changes when Michael
returns and Laurie Karen and Alison team
up to take him down it's discovered that
Michael psychiatrist dr. Sartain is
obsessed with him and was the one behind
his escape
eventually the Strode clan defeats
Michael with the power of fire and
Firearms but as we all know there's
probably no stopping this psycho slasher
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]